The late Dr. Martin Luther King once said, and I quote...
..."We must discover the power of love, the redemptive power of love.
And when we do that, we will make of this old world...
...a new world, for love is the only way."
There's power in love.
Don't underestimate it.
Don't even oversentimentalize it.
There's power, power in love.
If you don't believe me, think about a time when you first fell in love.
The whole world seemed to center around you and your beloved.
Oh, there's power, power in love.
Not just in its romantic forms, but any form, any shape of love.
There's a certain sense in which, when you are loved, and you know it,...
...when someone cares for you, and you know it,...
...when you love and you show it, it actually feels right.
There's something right about it.